hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
as you can guess from the title of her
address Audrey Lord thinks that there
are indeed legitimate and even
productive and positive uses of the
emotion of anger and she's providing us
with an argument why we shouldn't try to
force those who are in vulnerable
positions those who are discriminated
against those who encounter Injustice to
stifle their anger to not express it
because it does bother some people and
she's making some very strong claims
quite plausibly for why that anger needs
to be out there and she is not an
apologist for just shooting you know
anger out into the world willy-nilly she
talks about the need to focus with
Precision so she's not endorsing anger
just per se but she is telling us that
anger does have its uses and I would
like to point one thing out that she
does say towards the end of her piece
she says my anger has meant pain to me
but it's also meant survival before I
give it up I'm going to be sure that
there's something at least as powerful
to replace it on the road to Clarity so
she's not saying anger for its own sake
anger is wonderful anything like that
she's saying it can be a useful tool in
some respects and so let's take a look
at what she has to say she's got a
wonderful line from a poem where she
says everything can be used except what
is wasteful and so the question is is
anger something that is just wasteful is
does it waste our energy does it waste
our Attention our concentration does it
take our eyes off the prize so to speak
or can anger actually actually be used
for something effectively she tells us
anger is loaded with information
and energy and so that is kind of an
important point a little bit later she
also says any discussion among women
about racism must include the
recognition and the use of anger this
discussion must be direct and creative
because it is crucial we cannot allow
our fear of anger to deflect us nor
seduce us into settling for anything
less than the hard work of Excavating
honesty isn't that a wonderful phrase
right there instead of saying be
authentic Excavating honesty honesty is
something that has to be pulled out of
the ground with work and I think that's
that's a very good way of thinking about
it so
she tells us that we can learn from our
emotions or at least we can learn from
one emotion that she's going to talk
about in particular and that is anger
how can anger help us to understand our
situation to respond to it appropriately
this is a very important question and I
do want to point out that she is also
talking about three other emotions at
considerable length in here and she's
saying that we can't learn from them the
same way that we can from anger
obviously we can learn something from
any emotion and its responses so for
example fear guilt and hatred we can
learn how they work we can learn how
they arise
we can learn that this person over here
feels this fear in response to this
person's anger or that this person over
here is motivated by this hatred rather
than being motivated motivated by anger
but that is not the kind of teaching
that anger makes possible for us if
we're actually paying close attention to
it fear stands in the way of learning
guilt could in fact teach us something
because she tells us you know for
example when black women Express their
anger at white women in a feminist
movement which is what's going on here
and then the white women say you're
making me feel guilty that guilt is not
actually teaching them anything
necessarily the way that anger is
but guilt actually could help us if we
reflected on it to realize our own
shortcomings our own failures our own
injustices that we've committed and you
can't really learn from hatred the way
you can from anger either so what are
the things that you can learn what are
the uses that anger could be put to and
before we jump into the four that I
think are particularly
highlighted in her piece we should think
about this this word uses because she's
also going to use another
framework dealing with dealing with
other people's anger dealing with our
own anger use and dealing with in
English are two very different things
but it's interesting because what one
thing that we see when we look at
ancient philosophy whether it's
Aristotle or a stoic like Epictetus both
of whom talked at Great length about
anger it is that there is actually one
term that encompasses using on the one
hand and dealing with on the other in
Greek it's racist and it it means use
but it also does mean how we address
something
what what use we make of it in relation
to our own responses so anger can anger
actually do anything productive for us
so right after that poetic line
everything can be used except what is
wasteful which continues on saying you
might you will need to remember this
when you are accused of Destruction
she immediately says every woman has a
well-stocked arsenal of anger
potentially useful against those
oppressions personal and institutional
which brought that anger into being
focused with Precision anger she says
can become a powerful source of energy
serving progress and change and she also
specifies when I speak of change I don't
mean a simple switch of positions or a
temporary lessening of tensions nor the
ability to smile and feel good I am
speaking of a basic and radical
alteration in those assumptions
underlining our life so anger as an
emotion can provide us with energy
that then can be channeled into standing
up against and criticizing oppression
aggression uh exploitation domination
trying to produce lasting progress and
change not merely an accommodation to
the situation but a genuine criticism
and then trying to make things better
and this could be the case in individual
relationships I don't like the way that
you talk to me I'm angry with you about
that I think that you're showing me
fundamental disrespect in you know what
our relationship looks like it could be
in the workplace it could be in the
classroom it could be in you know
politics it could be in culture it could
be in all sorts uh venues especially on
the internet right people can push back
and anger gives them the energy to do
that so that's already one valuable use
of anger what else not long after that
she actually tells us that anger
expressed and translated into action in
the service of our vision and our future
is a liberating and strengthening Act of
clarification so this goes beyond merely
supplying energy for the fight or the
long struggle this is something
different there's a cognitive aspect a
genuine learning from anger and what
does she say that we can learn it's in
the painful process of this translation
we identify
who are our allies with whom we have
grave differences and who are our
genuine enemies you know the allies with
whom we have genuine differences allies
with whom we get angry at and those who
are genuine enemies those who are not
going to change unless something
radically changes within them those who
are not acting in Good Will but you know
screwing up nevertheless those who are
motivated by hatred the desire to
eradicate other people to exploit them
to force them down to keep them quiet
and complacent or at least compliant so
anger can in fact have this
clarificatory uh Force as well and she
says this can be quite difficult you
know I myself can realize that I have
been making other people angry by my
attitudes my actions and she says it's
very difficult to stand still and listen
to another woman's voice delineate and
Agony I do not share or one to which I
myself have contributed so we've got two
main uses of anger here a third
which we might call a sort of resiliency
or being able to
continue on in the face of things she
says my response to racism is anger the
anger is eaten clefs into my living only
when it remained unspoken useless to
anyone
it is also served me in classrooms
without light or learning where the work
and history of black women was less than
a vapor it has served me as fire in the
ice zone of the uncomprehending eyes of
white women who see in my experience and
the experience of my people only new
reasons for fear or guilt and so it's
something that can sustain one in the
lonely
unacknowledged perhaps even suppressed
situation that is uh partly provoking
that very anger but also needs to be
remedied and then finally she has a very
interesting follow-up to the clarity
thing this is towards the end of her
piece
and she says that
um
she's talking about not recognizing
other people if I fail to recognize
those others as faces of myself then I
am contributing not only to each of
their oppressions but also to my own and
the anger which stands between us then
must be used for what clarity
but also Mutual empowerment
not for evasion by guilt or further
separation
so another function of anger is mutual
empowerment and with what you know she
says afterwards I am not free while any
woman is unfree even when her shackles
are very different than my own and I am
not free as long as one woman one person
of color remains chained nor is any one
of you she's talking about anger's
capacity to be in solidarity
to support those who are being pushed
down and who are trying to rise up so
anger can be used for a lot of very
important purposes it can also be
misused for a variety of things anger
can be redirected you know she talks
about you know women who fear their
anger fear the expression but are fine
with turning it on other women who are
in you know lower positions than
themselves rather than against the those
who have actually angered them she also
talks about black women being expected
to use their anger only in the service
of other people's salvation or learning
and she says that's not really a
legitimate use of anger actually that's
counterproductive and we're going to get
rid of that so it's not as if anger
automatically has all sorts of wonderful
uses you actually have to work to use
anger in the right way and that is part
of what she is advocating in this piece
on the uses of anger